[Music]
after nearly 20 years of planning
norway's hotly anticipated new national
museum opened in oslo this summer
promising to help reshape the art scene
of northern europe it combines the
collections of four museums creating a
mammoth of art and culture with room for
a hundred thousand works including some
of the most famous pieces in the world
we traveled there for its opening week
and the start of a new chapter in
scandinavia
[Music]
for more than a hundred years this spot
on the oslo harbor where the city meets
the fjord marked the nexus of travel to
western norway
now there's hope to make this site of a
former train station a destination once
again
inside the imposing walls of the
national museum a vast and ambitious
effort to reshape the identity of
scandinavian art directed by karen
hinsbo when you open a national museum
you're also telling the story of a
nation
yes we want to tell the story about
norway but also to tell the story about
norway in the world
now one of europe's largest art museums
it merges four of norway's most
expansive collections including the
national gallery
it wasn't easy the project cost more
than 600 million dollars and took almost
20 years before finally opening this
june
how rare is it to build a world-class
museum
i think it's quite rare to get this
opportunity
in the 21st century
and of course we have been thinking a
lot about that what is a national museum
today what is an identity is it even
relevant to discuss a national identity
today but these are important questions
and we can raise them it wouldn't be a
national museum without norway's most
famous artist edvard monk
the scream his painting of an agonized
man mesmerizing visitors
then
and now would you say that that's one of
the the most well-known pieces of
of art here yes of course it's
it has its own emoji
you can't really top that
that's very true i've never thought of
it like that
the modern day interpretation perfectly
encapsulating life's unexpected moments
and one of the only originals lives here
this room is very special to the museum
yes that's true it's the home of the
main
the main home of edward moore's
paintings in our collection maya brick
ghouling curates the moon collection and
says the room's darkness helps preserve
the scream's delicate canvas
cardboard monk wanted to have a very
matte surface because that was part of
the message to the viewer
and in the sky you can read
with very tiny pencil
letters
must have been painted by a madman a
hidden message a hidden message and the
painting has plenty of its own stories
to tell especially after being taken in
1994. the scream by edward monk has been
stolen from norway's national gallery
the thieves seen in the security footage
climbed in through a window leaving
behind a note
thanks for the poor security
it was recovered about three months
later returned to its place as a
centerpiece of norwegian art history
what did it mean
to have this painting stolen
well it was devastating of course this
was one of the
main
attractions and main works in our
collection and of course really
important to the understanding of edward
monk's
art
the museum's collection also includes
royal fashion allowing visitors to get
up close to opulent and ornate dresses
once donned by norwegian queens
making modern history norwegian peter
dundas who crafted these designs for
international luminaries including
michelle obama
and kim kardashian
the eye-catching appeal of nordic taste
isn't limited to fashion denise
hochstrumer is the museum's senior
curator of design
so many of us in the world have been
influenced by scandinavian design and
don't even realize that
yes that's interesting isn't it
it's so ubiquitous
it's everywhere known for its minimal
and clean composition the confident
aesthetic combines functionality with
artistry
the intentional design seen in everyday
items from early cell phones to robotic
vacuums they will recognize many many
objects here and i've noticed that going
around and observing
our first visitors and they talk about
exhibits that they recognize and they
get all excited about you know seeing
them in in these cases the response
especially rewarding after the massive
effort to safely transport hundreds of
thousands of objects in the move
but the painstaking process of
cataloging each item to ensure nothing
was lost
also presented an unexpected gain it
gave us a whole new perspective and
knowledge of the collection we have four
hundred thousand objects in total you
don't go work with them every day but
when you certainly need to move them you
need to work with them in a different
way inside the museum's photography
studio curators are able to see works in
a new light using infrared cameras to
dive underneath layers of paint when you
talk about
the ability to not only revisit but
revisit with the best state-of-the-art
technology what do you discover we
discovered this sketch underneath
edward monk's madonna her arm was
originally painted in a whole different
way it's known as one of monk's most
controversial works but his sketch of
madonna underneath the final painting
reveals a more traditional and
conservative pose as he experimented
with ideas
and though the finished piece now hangs
in this gallery it's far from static
it's enduring legacy a gift for future
generations much like the museum itself
as it welcomes its visitors
what have you been hearing
people
may not like all the art or the
solutions but they have a really great
experience being here and that is also
the most important thing we're not here
to
provide consensus we're here to provide
a great space for different opinions
and there are a lot of different
opinions especially when you create what
is a national museum what do you do to
put something in it it can be subjective
and so it's part about eliciting that
conversation to begin with i love that
ability to look under the painting and
find what was the saturation starting
with scream is not a bad idea which i
had no idea was painted on cardboard or
the emoji for me